[Music]
so we Stewart you were named GQ
politician of the year and then in the
same week he had the whip withdrawn from
the Conservative Party how does it come
to that it was an amazing moment so it's
a great honor to get the award but one
of the things I feel very strong is that
a No Deal brexit would be very deeply
damaging and unnecessary so I voted to
block an ad or exit and then some what's
my surprise
although traditionally members of
parliament are able to vote with their
consciousness in this case the promise
responded by throwing me out of the
party you word that there were warnings
though yeah fully 45 minutes before I
voted I got a text saying that if I did
the paid I'd be thrown out but the only
formal confirmation we got from the
web's was 45 minutes before the vote
that that's what they were doing I'd had
a conversation with Boris in July when
he was taking over as leader where I
said look I'm against an ad or brexit
you know that our vote against NATO
breaks it so of course they can't serve
in your cabinet and that's the normal
convention you can't be in the
government to view against policy but
you can remain in Parliament so do you
hold it against Boris I did I suppose I
think it's a dangerous constitutional
precedent because I think that there's
not much point in Parliament if it can't
occasionally vote against the government
if the centre has the power to insist
that MPs always vote with the government
what's the point Department some of your
colleagues who had the wit withdrawn
have joined other parties you've said
your boy is a Tory yeah on what
conditions would you rejoin the Tory
party well I would need a pretty
astonishing apology from Boris and a
pretty clear explanation of why he's not
trying to turn the party into the brexit
party and a very clear explanation of
what kind of home he really has for
somebody like me within the party and
under a different leader I mean look I I
am a conservative I am conservative
because I believe in individual rights
and the mitad government's prudence at
home and abroad all these kind of things
but to return to a relationship you need
to get a very clear sense if somebody's
just throwing you out that they've truly
changed before you walking through the
door at them and that's not forthcoming
it no no I mean effectively I'm sitting
the garden shed
the gun and to get back into that house
you'd have to believe that your partner
really wanted you and they'd have to
explain what you were going to do
together how would you have changed the
party had you won the leadership an
action made us the party as the center
ground I would have said it's crazy to
have a politics divided between Nigel
Ferrara Corbin and that what we need to
do is to argue for bringing people
together not dividing and what would
you've done differently looking back at
those successive rounds of ballots in
Parliament that you almost got through
to the final round I would have been
much more punchy in the BBC de gate
against pirates I in a sense because I'm
conservative
I felt loyal towards my party I didn't
want to upset colleagues I was convinced
not to go blue on blue everybody said
take it easy
we've got a hold the party together
don't attack Morris actually I would
have done much better going big or going
home and really going after him in that
debate
we've reached such level of public
consciousness partly through your ad
direct posting of videos around the
country on Twitter um it's a tactic that
Boris seems to pick up on in office
doing you know people's people's some
Prime Minister's Questions Trump Trump
does a lot as well do you think there's
a danger in politicians directly posting
videos on online where I think the for
me we have to be trumpian anti Trump's
we have to take the techniques the
populist and use it to advocate for the
center ground if I'd seeded social media
to the extremes then we're in real
trouble
do you think there's a incongruent
perhaps between you're very polite
mannered public persona and some aspects
of your voting record within Parliament
my voting record is the varying record
of a conservative so it's exactly the
same as any other Conservative
government ministers so people who voted
against the Conservative Party and
against the conservative manifesto would
be deeply against the way that I voted I
felt that I stood on a conservative
manifesto and that it was my obligation
to my voters to fulfill that and when I
rebelled on an ad or breck said I
rebelled because I felt that I stood on
a manifesto for an orderly departure
from the European Union not for this so
your app see right if you come from the
Corbyn left you would feel that many of
the things like that
are things that you deeply of it and
will you be standing as an independent
in the next election I'm still thinking
about my options
have you had offers from other parties
other parties have tried to talk to me
but I I didn't talk to them I'm not very
keen on it standing on that would you
rather have a confirmatory referendum
under a Corbin governments or proceed
along the grounds that we seem to be
going along with an automatic No Deal
what we've just proved is that's a
completely false choice I mean
everyone's been trying to do that to me
for six months now would you like Corbin
what would you like no do and I keep
saying you don't need no you can prevent
their deals through Parliament's what I
just did that's what I just sacrificed
my my seat in parliament to proof that
you don't need to choose call them to
stop and they do come and do you think
you have the support within your
constituency to succeed without the
official backing of your party
it'll be very tough and if you look at
the polling I might just make it I might
not have probably within about a
thousand votes good luck thank you very
much indeed thank you for having me take
care time for more debates talks and
interviews subscribe today to the
Institute of Arts and ideas at AI TV
you